>> HOW BAD IS MICHAEL AVENATTI
HIS LAWYERS ARE BAD.
A CALIFORNIA JUDGE DISMISSED
STORMY DANIEL'S DEFAMATION SUIT
AND ORDERED HER TO PLAY TRUMP'S
LEGAL FEES.
NOW WHEN JUDGES DO THAT IT'S TO
SEND A MESSAGE.
YOUR LAWYER'S A MORON.
POOR STORMY, AS A RULE PEOPLE
PAY HER FOR SEX AND NOW AVENATTI
REVERSED IT.
HE CHASED SPOT LIGHTS AN WHEN HE
CATCHES THEM HE LOOKS
RIDICULOUS.
HE'S GOOD AT COSTING HIS OWN
SIDE MONEY.
HIS FIRM WAS ORDER TO PAY $10
MILLION TO AN ATTORNEY WHO ONCE
WORKED THERE AND WHAT ABOUT THE
KAVANAUGH DEBACLE AND MANY FLED
SENSING THEY WERE BECOMING HIS
VICTIMS TOO.
WHY COMPLAIN.
SHE'S BAIN DISASTER FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
ARE WE SURE HE WASN'T ON TRUMP'S
PAYROLL ALL ALONG.
NOW HE'S TAKEN TO CHALLENGING
PEOPLE TO FIGHT ON TWITTER LIKE
A TOWN-
A TOW POLUCA.
HOW DOES THE TRICKSTER GET AWAY
WITH IT?
DOES THE STATE BAR CARE ABOUT
ETHICS.
ISN'T THERE A DISCIPLINARY
COMMITTEE OR IS HE EXEMPT
BECAUSE HE'S A LIBERAL ATTACK
DOG.
HIS PUNISHMENT SHOULD BE HARSH.
MAKE HIM REPRESENT HIMSELF.
HE'S GOING TO RUN, DANA.
>> HE IS RUNNING.
MAYBE THIS COULD BE GREET FOR
HIM.
MAYBE HE DOESN'T CARE.
>> HE DOES PROVIDE A LOT OF
FODDER.
I'M SURE THE DEMOCRATS WISH HE
WOULD JUST GO AWAY OR BECOME A
REPUBLICAN.
>> HE COULD RUN WITH LIZ.
WHAT A TICKET.
>> THEY CAN COME UP WITH OTHER
IDEA.
I DO WONDER IF AVENATTI WILL
HELP STORMY DANIELS PAY THE
LEGAL FEES.
>> HER GO FUND ME PAGE WHICH IS
FLOODED WITH MONEY WITH PEOPLE
WHO HATE TRUMP WILL GO TO TRUMP.
>> TRUMP ALWAYS MAKES MONEY.
>> I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
HITCHED THEIR RIDE TO THE WRONG
HORSE.
HE'S TAKEN THE DEMOCRATS FOR A
RIDE AND IT WON'T BE A VICTORY
LAP.
THE PRESIDENT OBVIOUSLY SAID
SHE'S A HORSEFACE OR WHATEVER ON
TWITTER AND NOW ANYBODY ON THE
LEFT IS UPSET.
I WOULDN'T SAY THAT BUT HERE'S
WHAT I WOULD SAY, THE LEFT HAS
USED THE WORD "C" WORD TO
DESCRIBE PEOPLE IN THE TRUMP
FAMILY AND EVERYBODY APPLAUDED
THAT.
THEY FANTASIZED ABOUT KILLING
THE PRESIDENT AND NOW THEY'RE
CLUTCHING THEIR PEARLS WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAYS THE WORD "HORSE
FACE"?
PLEASE, YOU'RE SURPRISED DONALD
TRUMP SAYS THING ABOUT PEOPLE,
EITHER YOU HAVEN'T LEARNED
ANYTHING OR YOUR DENSE.
THIS IS WHAT HE DOES AND HOW HE
WINS.
NOW REGARDING THE OTHER CLAIM
ABOUT THE GANG RAPE CASE, THAT
BEING SO FALSE IN AND OF ITSELF
MAKES ME THINK MAYBE DONALD
TRUMP DIDN'T HAVE AN AFFAIR WITH
STORMY DANIELS.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT STORMY
DANIELS HAVE ALSO SAID NOT SO
NICE THING ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S EXPERIENCE.
THERE'S THINGS WE WILL NOT
REPEAT.
AVENATTI 2020 WILL BE LIT AS THE
KIDS SAY AND I THINK HE'LL BE
UPSET HE WAS INVOLVED.
THEY THINK THE REASON THEY LOST
THE KAVANAUGH FIGHT IS HE GOT
INVOLVED AND PUTTING STORMY
DANIELS IN A POSITION WHERE HE
WON'T PAY THE LEGAL BILLS FOR
HER AND WILL FIND SOME OTHER
WOMAN TO JUMP INTO THIS TRAP OF
POLITICS CLAIMING HE WILL
REPRESENT HER AND IT WILL BE
GREAT, THEY'RE GOING TO WIN AND
YET HIS TRACK RECORD SHOWS THE
OPPOSITE.
IT'S NOT FOR WOMEN GETTING
INVOLVED, WARNING, YOU SEE HIM
KNOCKING ON YOUR DOOR, TELL HIM
TO GO AWAY.
WHEN IT COMES TO COMPLICATIONS
FOR WHAT HE'S DONE --
>> WELL, THE KIDS SAY HIS
CAMPAIGN IS LIT?
>> LIT.
LIKE ON FIRE.
IT'S GOING TO BE EXCITING TO
WATCH.
>> I THINK DANA AND GREG HAD IT
RIGHT.
IT WILL BE FUN FOR US.
>> THAT'S WHAT I MEAN.
>> TO ME THE HORSE FACE STUFF,
BY THE WAY, COME ON.
YOU SAY IT'S TYPICAL TRUMP BUT
CARLY FIORINA AND I THINK, MAN,
AT SOME POINT AMERICAN WOMEN ARE
LIKE THIS GUY'S --
>> AND SOMETHING ABOUT IMPORTANT
STARS.
>> I SEE.
I THINK IT'S ALL WOMAN IN TERMS
OF HIS ATTITUDE.
I THINK THE REAL INTERESTING
THING HERE IS HOW THE RIGHT IS
MAKING THIS OUT TO BE SUCH A BIG
WIN.
TOTAL VINDICATION FOR DONALD
TRUMP WHEN THIS ISN'T THE MAIN
CASE.
THE MAIN CASE HAS TO DO WITH THE
NON-DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT.
THIS WAS ABOUT THE UNKNOWN GUY
IN THE PARKING LOT --
>> DO YOU THINK PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT THE NON-DISCLOSURE?
>> MY POINT TO YOU IS THIS CASE
IS NOT SETTLED.
>> HERE'S THE ISSUE, THIS WAS
THE CASE THEY JUST WON WAS
PROBABLY THE STRONGEST ONE
BECAUSE TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
HUSH AGREEMENT SHE TOOK THE
MONEY.
IT WILL BE HARD FOR HER TO BE
PROVEN TO BE RIGHT IF SHE'D
TAKEN THE MONEY.
>> SHE SAID IN FACT IT WASN'T
PROPERLY SIGNED AND MICHAEL
COHEN WHO NOW -- I DON'T KNOW
WHERE HE STANDS -- THIS IS WHERE
THE CONVERSATION -- NOT ONLY
HERE BUT IN AMERICA HAS GONE.
MICHAEL AVENATTI HAD A
RELATIONSHIP?